I've discovered something recently about
my 30-minute reversal timing in the
markets that instead allows you to look
at a few key factors and know when it's
not going to do that and you can
actually take a continuation trade. And
so this is something that's repeatable
every morning of looking for the market
to either reverse at a key level or
break through a key level and you can
take trades on either direction. And so
normally every morning I look for key
levels and look for things to reverse.
But instead, sometimes when if we just
zoom out here on a 5-minute chart of the
Nasdaq is when things are so bullish,
it's more likely to continue breaking
through resistance levels and you don't
want to be counter trend trading in that
plate at that point. You want to be
trying to buy the breakouts and get in
on the pushes higher. So to show you a
real trade of this, normally I draw my
levels off of a 15-minute chart. If we
zoom out, you can see we're in a really
strong uptrend right now. And so, you
know, any previous resistance level
we've blown through and even I can't
even zoom so far back on a 15-minute
chart. You have to zoom all the way out
on a daily chart to see essentially this
previous all-time high actually of on
the Nasdaq of where that level is and so
where we could potentially break out of.
And so from there, going into a 5-minute
chart, this is kind of what I was
looking at this day is I was looking at
okay, we're coming up into this level
and then zooming in on a 1-minute chart,
what that looks like is, you know,
again, looking for my 30-minute reversal
timing. Market opens up at 7:30, we kind
of started to push higher and we come up
into about 8:00. We come up into this
resistance zone and start to slow down.
We kind of start to make a double top
here and it's not a crazy big double
top. And so the reason why I didn't
technically take a short here because if
you look at this, it kind of hits my
normal checklist. We came up to a
resistance zone, we broke this trend
line and we've made kind of a double top
and a potential reversal bar right here
as well. But the thing is with trading,
the most important thing always is not
these little micro patterns that you
look at on a smaller time frame chart
when you're entering is it's the big
picture. And the big picture is that
this market is really bullish right now.
Going back to that daily chart is look
at how this box is huge. And so you can
see that the day did close up pushing
the highs of this box, but right now
when it's opening and we're looking for
this reversal is it's right here, right?
It's right at essentially the bottom of
this box. Looking at a 5-minute chart,
you can see the kind of it moves up here
and we're starting to just have a
consolidation, a bull flag as you might
say. And so that's why the big picture
is important and the reason why is
because that allows me to say, "Hey, I
actually don't want to bet short here.
I'm going to hold off and save my money.
You know, maybe I could be wrong and it
could reverse here and I'll miss out on
a nice swing, but you have to go with
your read. Otherwise, you're just kind
of blindly following
a plan and rules and you have to go with
the overall big picture. That's the most
important part. That's the hard part
about trading is it is a little
subjective, but going into this, that's
what you have to kind of do sometimes.
And so, you know, the Nasdaq just kind
of was chopping here, right? And so when
it gets into that point, a lot of times
what I want to see is a big bearish
candlestick here and what that does is
when the market's chopping so much and
just a big candle out of nowhere
happens, a lot of people get FOMO.
They'll jump in and and it'll bait them.
And so what I like to see is it kind of
start to quickly reverse that. And so
when that happens and it aligns up with
your overall idea that we're going to
actually push higher, that is a very
good signal to I think jump in long. And
so I actually jumped in after that
signal. I actually waited for one more
little pullback here as it pushed
higher, baited people. Essentially it it
there's a tiny little box right here,
right? And it broke the lows
essentially, you know, breakout traders
and previous old me that maybe wouldn't
have seen these signals when I was kind
of new to reversing, I would have gotten
short here because this looks like a
nice bear breakout, right? But again,
using that overall picture is I actually
think this is going to go up. And so we
then got a couple of candles here where
it kind of just sits here. And so going
into the recording of this in real time
again to show you is that's where I got
long as I jumped in right after
basically this kind of pullback here and
then I put my stop loss below this low
and I bet that the market was going to
go higher. This is nerve-wracking for
me. It's kind of not the norm versus
betting that the market's going to go
down, but when all those things are
aligning and you have this kind of fake
lower and this fake lower and you have
that bigger picture trend that's really
strong is that's where I like to jump
in. You know, you can take that
30-minute timing and say, "Okay, well,
it's not working today because of few
factors and I can profit off of that in
a different way." And so once it kind of
breaks out up here, I moved my stop loss
to break even because, you know, if this
just kind of pukes back down right here,
the market's just in a really choppy
state and you just want to get out of
that point. The idea is that it's going
to break out here and you're going to
find some momentum and you're going to
be able to capture a profitable trade.
And so from here, once we start to break
out, you can see it's, you know, I'm I'm
making really good money off this trade
and this move is happening really nicely
and, you know, just one direction. And
so when the market moves up so quickly
like that, I like to trail up my stop
loss and get out, you know, when it
starts to turn quickly because I want to
maximize my profits. And so I jump out
on, you know, 2/3, 3/4 of my trade right
there. And then what I do is I allow
kind of I leave a little bit on with the
idea that what this does is when you're
trading, you're going to have all these
emotions in your mind of, "Well, what if
it just keeps going higher and, you
know, I closed out all of my trades and
I missed out, right?" Or what if this is
it and I should have got out here and it
just reverses. And so I I find scaling
out a certain amount over time allows me
to mentally deal with that. I can get
out, 2/3, 3/4 of my trade, whatever
makes sense, at, you know, two or three
times my risk or when kind of, you know,
a big tight move up like this has broken
clearly right here. And then I can
slowly manage the rest of the trade
because it'll allow me to, you know, get
a little bit more if there is a little
bit more in the trade. You know,
sometimes the market can go 5, 10x my
trades. Doesn't happen very often, but
when it does, I like to be on that ride.
And so from here, you know, the market
just kind of moves up pretty quick and
and I kind of try and trail up this a
little bit more and get out and I think,
you know, that trade closed up probably
$900 or something and it was a great
trade. And so the same thing happened
where, you know, I was done by 9:00,
which was a little longer, but an hour
and a half, 90 minutes and I can move on
with the day. And so if you want to
learn that more about this strategy,
check out this playlist right here.
It'll talk you through everything more
about entering and managing these
trades, finding the key support and
resistance levels and also talking about
those candlestick patterns that are so
important to finally entering in on the
trade.